let's figure out what 2.2 1 1 / 6.7 is
so the first thing I like to do is I
don't like to divide by a decimal so I'm
going to multiply 6 point 7 I'm going to
multiply 6 point 7 by 10 which is
essentially just taking this decimal
space this is decimal and moving it one
space to the right well I can't just do
that to the six point seven I also have
to do that to the two point two one so
let me move its decimal one space to the
right and so now I can rewrite the
problem I can rewrite it as 22 22 point
22 point 1 1 / / instead of writing it
as 6 point 7 I can now write it as 67 67
let me do it in that same color I can
now write it as 67 now I could write a
decimal right over here but that's not
going to change the fact that this is
just now the whole number 67 and so now
I'm ready to do some long division now
that I'm dividing by a whole number you
might say wait I still have a decimal
over here but that's okay and you're
going to see that in a second so let's
try to do some long division so we're
going to take we're going to take 22 22
point 1 1 or 22 and 11 hundredths and we
are going to divide it let me write that
a little bit bigger just so we have some
space 22 point 1 1 and we are going to
divide that by we are going to divide
that by 67 67 all right let's do some
long division now and actually before we
even do that I like to keep track of my
decimal so my decimal is over here I'm
going to write my decimal right over
here in the answer and when you're doing
these long division problems is really
important to write things neatly and and
keep things in nice columns and keep
track of your place value because if you
don't write things in neat columns and
frankly you'll probably lose track of
your place value but let's do this
so 67 goes into 2 zero times so let's
move on 67 goes into 22 0 times 60 seven
goes into 221 so let's think about that
a little bit this is pretty close to 70
seventy times three would be two hundred
and ten so this looks like maybe three
times three times seems about right so
let's try let's put a 3 up here 3 times
7 is 21 carry the 2 3 times 6 is 18 plus
2 is 20 is 20 so we get 201 and the
difference between 221 and 201 is going
to be well you just get a 0 here you get
a 2 here then you get a 0 here I don't
have to write it it's 20 so 3 was right
if if 3 times 67 were higher than 221
then we'd be in trouble and then if 3 if
3 times 67 were lower but it was so low
that though that when you subtracted you
got a number higher than 67 then that
means you could have thrown in more 67 s
in there but this number is just right
it's lower but our remainder is less
than is less than a 67 so let's keep
going so now we can bring down we can
bring down the 1 and we see 67 goes in
to 201 well we just figure that out 67
goes in to 201 3 times 3 times 3 times 7
is 1 carry the 2 got to make sure we
don't well if we're doing the same
problem as we did before but it's good
to not have the the previous 2 there
sometimes you like you might want to
erase it you have 3 times 6 is 18 plus 2
is 20 and now you subtract and we are
done because we have no remainder and
there's nothing there's nothing here
left to bring down and so 22 point 1 1
divided by 67 is and we could throw a 0
here just for good measure its 0.33 0.33
this is equal to 0.33 or this is equal
to 0.33 and we're done